Have your club's Toastmasters meetings
gotten a little bit stale?
In this video, I'm going to provide you
with a few ideas of how you can shake
things up when it comes to a
Toastmasters meeting. Whether you're a
club member who wants to propose these
ideas to your club, or maybe you've
signed up already to be Toastmaster, and
you want to surprise the club with one
of these ideas, I think it will go over
very well. The first way you can shake
up a Toastmasters meeting is by making a
rule that nobody can use notes when
presenting to the rest of the group.
Now, [snorts] that might be easy for
some roles, like the toast or the
humorist or the inspirational speaker,
but that is going to be challenging for
any sort of report roles, like the ah
counter or the grammarian or the timer.
So, it's going to force those people to
adapt in how they present. Now, they can
take notes while they're sitting down,
and this is especially important for
evaluators who are evaluating speakers,
because then they can still give all of
their thoughts to that speaker
afterward, but this forces us to really
detach from the notes, and almost have
an impromptu sense of how are we going
to fill the time if we're not relying on
reading off of a sheet of paper. And so,
I think that this is a really great
challenge. Obviously, you don't want to
do that every single week at a club,
but why not propose it for one of your
clubs? It'll be something incredibly
unique, and it'll push your Toastmasters
members to elevate their skill. The next
way you can change up a Toastmasters
meeting to make it a little bit more
interesting is spontaneously adjusting
the timing of roles.
As an example, maybe for a speech
evaluation, rather than having it be two
to three minutes, you make it three to
four minutes. And for the grammarian
report, instead of being one to two
minutes, you make it 30 seconds to one
minute.
This is going to take a little bit of
work on your part to do the math to
ensure it still fills the full time of
the meeting without going too long, but
by forcing people to adjust their
timing, that is simulating a real-life
circumstance because at live events,
depending if the agenda is moving
quicker or slower, it's a regular thing
that speakers are asked to reduce their
speaking time or to speak for longer.
And by getting in the habit of this with
smaller meeting roles,
it's not something you want to do every
single week, but as a way to spice it up
one week at a Toastmasters meeting, it
could be a great idea. Another
outside-the-box idea for how you can
make a Toastmasters club meeting really
interesting is by not only picking a
theme, but really committing to it.
An example of this, the theme could be a
wedding where you encourage
guests or members of the Toastmasters
club to actually wear formal wear to the
meeting and ensure that their roles are
adjusting to a real-life circumstance
almost as if they were attending the
wedding. So though the individual who
gives the toast, that is an actual toast
that they would give to the bride and
the groom. And you, as the Toastmaster
of the meeting, treat it almost like
you're the MC of a wedding. You could
have introductions for different roles
that make them feel like the bridal
party. There's all sorts of creative
possibilities,
but by whatever you want to do with
this, pick a theme, but then go over the
top, get people to dress up for it, and
get them to really commit, and make it
almost as if that theme is coming to
life. I was chatting with another member
of our Kelowna AM Toastmasters Club, and
she had an incredible idea of doing a
last-second mix-up of the roles at a
Toastmasters meeting.
So, imagine this. You show up to a
meeting, and you think you're taking on
the ah-counter role, but you find out
you're actually evaluating a speech. Or
you think you're giving the toast, and
then you learn you're actually doing the
humorist role.
Now, I understand there are some roles,
such as the speaker, where this might
not be possible, but by everyone
thinking that they have the agenda in
advance, and then you printing a brand
new agenda, and putting it in front of
everyone prior to the meeting, what a
great way to practice our skills of
adapting. Because adaptability is one of
the most important skills to have as a
speaker, and the reality is, in real
life, we will get thrown curveballs that
we need to adapt to as speakers. And so,
this type of meeting could really help
club members prepare for those real-life
circumstances. Another way you can make
your Toastmasters Club meeting more
interesting is by giving each person who
has a role a specific
item to focus on when they are speaking.
So, perhaps for the evaluators, you
write down on a little sheet of paper,
"Eye contact." Now they know that along
with giving their evaluation, you really
want them to focus on effective eye
contact. Maybe for the timer, you
challenge them with vocal variety.
Especially considering the timer role is
a little bit redundant as you say. Sue,
you spoke for 56 seconds. James, you
spoke for 1 minute 30 seconds. Often
it's a monotone role, so by encouraging
the vocal variety and the excitement,
that might help that role out. So you
create these different random things to
focus on that keeps your Toastmasters
member on their toes. It's a unique
challenge. It's something different and
it might go over very well if you happen
to be the Toastmaster. The spirit behind
all of these ideas of how to make a
Toastmasters club meeting more
interesting is to ensure that we know
how as Toastmasters to adapt to
situations.
It makes it more interesting to
participate in. It could be fun. It
could be a good laugh if it's really
challenging for various speakers.
Not every meeting is going to be
completely adapted this way, but by
spicing it up, shaking it up every now
and then, it keeps your club's meetings
as interesting and as engaging as
possible. But let me know in the
comments, has your Toastmasters club
done anything unique? What other ideas
do you have for this concept? Make sure
you let me know in the comments below.
If you have not already done so, please
subscribe to my channel. This is the
best way for you to stay informed on all
of the ways you can be a more impactful
communicator and check out the video
that is popping up right now because
this is a deep dive into taking on the
Toastmaster role. Thank you so much for
watching this video.